it is no secret that we love all things
design on this show i wanted it to be a
big part of the show because it's a big
part of my life so when we heard the
design dilemma of our next guest we were
excited to help create a brand new
segment we're calling design court
both sides will escape their cases and
by the end of this trial we will reach a
design verdict
take a look at the phil potts design
dilemma
hi drew my name is cass my name is ted
and we're the philpotts
we are hoping that you can help us
settle a design issue in our home
basically we've been in this house for
about 15 years we have redone all the
other rooms to suit our lifestyle with
the exception of this one the room is
called the back 40 because it tends to
be the catch-all for the house and i
would like to see it be more of a
tranquil space a quiet place to escape
everything from the house clean lines
quiet colors calm furniture and a place
just to retreat what i'd like to do is
something a little bit more
entertainment style pub style game room
style theater style so maybe a big tv a
shuffle board table some large couches
something comfortable for
myself our friends my daughter and her
friends to hang out and relax a little
bit so a day in the life of phil potts
you see we don't agree so we need help
we could not start a trial without drew
crew member and my partner in crime of
design michael wells hey friend
good to see you again i hate the idea of
you know working against you usually
we're a team i know but you know what a
little fun banter never hurt
let's do that let's do it all right well
it is time to meet our design litigants
cass and ted philpott come on out
[Applause]
well
design court is now in session uh-oh all
right mikael is representing ted and i
will be representing cass now cass let's
start with your opening statement please
address the court with your vision for
the room
so we have such crazy busy lives as it
is that i feel like our home should be
our sanctuary and we should have a space
to retreat from all the togetherness so
i would like to see the room be a design
that's
for solitude peace
and just some alone time and
is it correct um that you read like two
to three books a week i do
a day
i am an avid reader do you hear that
macau i heard it
all right i heard it ted state your case
she's not wrong uh our life is hectic
and she has a beautiful comfortable room
in the living room and the bathroom the
bedroom and the patio outside to read
plenty of books as long as she wants to
that's a lot of room
[Laughter]
we also do a lot of entertaining and we
need a space that brings a little bit of
life to the house um some sort of game
room some place where our younger
daughter and her friends can hang out
someplace i can unwind and kind of get
away from the hectic life that she's
trying to escape well i thank you
councils for excellent opening
statements good arguments well the jury
is still out
[Music]